what is the issue now what is going to  Define 2023 and 2024 the issue now I  have argued for  some months  is is more meta political than political  by which I mean it's not just that we're  fighting one issue Or Another We're not  just fighting taxes we're not just  fighting regulation we're not just  fighting abortion even we got the Dobbs  decision Roe v Wade is dead there's  still a lot of work to do in the  pro-life movement to protect babies but  even that that's not the  the most important issue in most  people's perception even if it is the  most important issue ultimately because  it's an issue of human life what I think  people are focused on and will  increasingly be focused on is  metapolitics the politics of politics  how decisions are made how power is  wielded in our country knowing that our  government is not run like the bill up  on Capitol Hill like our Founders and  framers intended